what are the solutions to the system of
equation system of equations y is equal
to one-half x + 2 x squared - y squared
is equal to 7 and they say solutions
because this could these two if we view
them as two line or two curves they
could very well intersect with each
other twice so let's see what's going on
here we have y is equal to 1/2 x + 2 x
squared - y squared is equal to 7 and
the best way to approach these is just
try to substitute one constraint into
the other constraint or substitute one
equation into the other one it seems
easier to substitute 1/2 X for Y into
this equation because they've already
solved for y here here it's much harder
to solve for X or Y so let's do that
every place we see a y here let's
substitute it with this that Y must also
be equal to 1/2 X and then see if we can
solve for X so on this equation we have
2x squared - y squared but now we're
saying that Y we're now saying that Y
must also be equal to 1/2 X and that is
going to be equal to 7 now let's see if
we can solve for X doing a little bit of
algebraic manipulation so we get 2x
squared - so 1/2 squared is 1/4 and then
x squared so we could say x squared /
let me write that as 1 for it so let's
say it's 1/4 1/4 x squared is equal to 7
so I have 2 X Squared's and I subtract
out a 1/4 x squared so I'm going to have
a 1 and 3/4 x squared or you could view
this as 8/4 minus 1/4 is 7/4 x squared
7/4 x squared is equal to 7 multiply
both sides times the reciprocal of 7/4
so 4/7 times multiply both sides by 4
sevenths and we get we get x squared is
equal to 4x squared is equal to 4 and so
X could be positive or negative
- it's the positive and negative square
root of 4 so X is equal to the plus or
minus square root of 4 X is equal to
positive 2 positive 2 or negative 2
now given that X is positive 2 or
negative 2 let's substitute back into
either of these equations to figure out
what Y is what the corresponding Y is
for each of these so if X is 2 y is
going to be 1/2 of that it's going to be
1 so we have the point 2 comma 1 all I
did is say look X is 2 1/2 times 2 is 1
if X is negative 2 if X is negative 2
then Y is going to be 1/2 times negative
2 which is going to be negative 1 and
you can both of these definitely satisfy
this first constraint and you can verify
that they also satisfy this second
constraint right over here 2 times 2
squared is well 2 squared is 4 2 times
that is 8 minus 1 squared is 7 2 times
negative 2 squared is still this holder
is going to be 8 minus negative 1
squared still equals 7 so the solutions
to the system of equation 1 is the
coordinate 2 comma 1 X is 2 y is 1 the
other is a coordinate negative 2
negative 1 X is negative 2 and Y is
negative 1